موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قال الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان انا لبلاده حقا مشروعا في
التحرك خارج الحدود لحمايه امنيه وفي
اشاره للعمليه العسكريه التي تشمها قوات
بلادي في شمال سوريا والعراق قال الرئيس
التركي وانه ليس بامكاني احد منعه انقره
من استخدام هذا الحاقه
نظره العمليه البريه التركيه في شمال
السوري بعد توزيع القوات التركيه سيدافها
للمواقع التي صدفتها هناك مؤكده مواصله
عمليتها ضد من سمتهم الارهابيين في شمالي
سوريا والعراق كما اعلنت القوات التركيه
مقتل احد جنودها برصاص مسلح حزب العمال
الكردستاني لما قالت ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه الى القصف التركيه جميله مطار
في حلب وعين العرب كوباني ومناطق في الرقه
والحسد
قال المتحدث باسم الكربلاند بيتري بيسكوفي
ان هناك خلافات مع تركيا بشان سوريا لكنه
اضاف ان مستوى علاقات البلدين والحكمه
السياسيه يسمحان بحل كل هذه الخلافات من
خلال محادثات المكثفه
تحتزم المعارك في اوكرانيا على طول خط
الجبهه في اقليم دونتس ووجان وتبادلت
القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه القصف في
خرسون حيث تحاول القوات الاوكرانيه ضربه
طرق الامداد بين نهر دنيبر والقرد اما
القوات الروسيه فتسعى الى ضرب البنيه
التحتيه الاخرانيه
واعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها
سدتها هجمات اوكرانيه على محور ريدونيسكو
وقالت سلطات الدونات المواليه لروسيا اين
قصف مدفعيه الاوكرانيا استهدفا مباني
سكنيه وسط المدينه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان لدى
القوات الاوكرانيه بصوارخ ارض جو عاليه
الدقه من طراز برنستون 2 كجزء من حزمه
مساعدتها العسكريه لاوكرانيا واقله
الوزاره ان هذه المساعدات دورا الحاسما في
عرقله التقدم الروسي
اندلعت احتجاجات في مدينه شنغهاي الصينيه
للمطالبه برفع القيود المشدده المفروضه
منذ ثلاث سنوات من قبل السلطات بسبب تفشي
فيروس كورونا وامتدت المظاهرات الى مدن
اخرى بينها بيجين واوهان بؤره ظهور
الفيروس ياتي ذلك وسط تقارير رسميه فادت
بتسجيل الصين اكثر من 36,000 اصابه امس
الاحد ولم يصدر اي تعليق الرسميين من
الحكومه الصينيه حتى الان
في الولايات المتحده قال مدير المعهد
الوطني الامريكي للحساسيه والامراض
المعديه وكبير مستشار اداره بايدن انتوني
فاوتشي قال انه يجب نسيان فكره ان كرونا
انتهى في الولايات المتحده واضاف ان
الفيروس يتسبب في موت قرابه 400 شخص يوميا
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]